non
[Musique]
et
go
non
oh
l'eau
[Musique]
un sens de circulation dans le dojo on
leur fait aussi le nettoyage des mains
et des pieds avant qu'ils montent sur le
tapis nous avons des studios de
répétition avec un marquage au sol qui
permet de de respecter la distanciation
le nettoyage des studios régulier en
termes de désinfection
lorsque des groupes se succèdent port du
masque obligatoire
prise de température gel hydroalcoolique
et sens de la marche pour nos événements
et pour l'instant on organise que des
événements en extérieur à la piscine en
face de porter le masque déjà pour les
plus de 11 ans et puis surtout de
d'éduquer au lavage de mains au savon
qui est quand même le plus efficace à
chaque début et chaqra en activité
[Musique]
une fête incontournable retrouvailles la
vie convivialité génovéfains festif
inclusion curieux au moment de partage
[Musique]